three-two-one drones can take our breath
away by giving us views we've never seen
before or solving problems like
delivering medicine and hard-to-reach
places but now they're also at the
center of a mystery this video taken
last week in northeast Colorado is a
piece of a puzzle no one has solved it's
so weird how it's moving and I'm not
moving my phone at all that's the little
device it's drones that have been
spotted flying at night in patterns over
different areas of rural Colorado and
Nebraska it's been going on for the past
several weeks and no one knows who's
operating them or their purpose the
number of drones reported to be seen at
a time ranges from four to over twelve
with wingspans estimated to be six feet
long flying anywhere from 100 to 500
feet in the air local law enforcement
and the FAA are investigating but as
long as drone operators abide by certain
rules there's technically nothing
illegal going on dusty Burge is
president of UAV recon a company that
utilizes drones to do tasks like inspect
power lines the scale of this operation
is very unique that to my knowledge it's
the first time something of this scale
has happened so I can understand why
people are concerned or curious
speculation obviously continuing the US
Army and DEA says it's not us some
people think it may be mapping tools
since it's being done in rural areas at
night some people have questioned if
they can shoot these down and they
remind it is illegal to shoot at Airmen
that absolutely is not a good idea yeah
not a good idea there are we sure
they're drunk they say they are drones
they're meeting again in later this
month to some of the different agencies
to try to figure out what exactly is
going on right be watching that's right
you